you want a perfect story
well first you need illegal aliens
then you got to add a bald eagle
and then finally let one eat the other
and you get
[Music]
the perfect story
it's a story so on the nose you think we
made it up but it's true to illegal
aliens for Honduras were busted in
Nebraska after allegedly shooting a bald
eagle to death did the intention of
cooking it and then eating it for dinner
I hear they taste just like chicken
so do the Eagles
oh I insulted the bald eagle killers
seriously though what a story illegals
eating a bald eagle the only thing
missing is them using an American flag
it's a tablecloth
it was an act so repulsive just about
everyone is asking why except for the
cast of The View who asked if it comes
with their choice of sides
foreign
authorities say the creeps use these air
rifles to slay our beloved bird or as
Democrats call them AK-47 grenade
launchers
also reportedly lopped off the eagles
feet so they could turn the talents into
ornaments
because if you're going to violate a
country's borders and its national
symbol be sure to accessorize
but from a sheer symbolism perspective
can you give a more Stark example of an
attack on American sovereignty and all
that it means to be an American
for my sheer symbolism perspective can
you give me a stock example of an attack
on American sovereignty and all that it
means to be American then the killing of
a bald eagle wow no I can't
and neither can we you know what it's
like it's like copping a feel of the
Statue of Liberty yeah pervert
the feds already let the men go but they
have a court appearance next month so
we'll never see them again
lastly we heard they were headed to
Canada to dine on something ethnic
Joe
uh you know when I you know when a story
is too on the nose it's a two red meat
story it's like yeah you could take
something from column A you know
illegals call them B an American symbol
and then you put put it together push it
together and you have the perfect Fox
and Friends Story the kind that gets
kill me all sweaty yeah like if this is
true if this had been a political
cartoon the editor would have sent it
back and said you're really pushing your
luck on this one and the only way to
know where's it did they have sex with
the bird before they ate it I mean
that's the only thing I can think of uh
yeah I'd have to say that people who
want to uh kill and eat a bald eagle not
likely to keep their Court appearances
yeah I don't think they show up for
things like that I think what we need to
do is find them and we need to exact the
proper Revenge which is to cover them
with little tiny fish put them in a
stadium and release a thousand bald
eagles to tear them limp from limb and I
would I would pay many many dollars to
see that well you're a sick man I
certainly am
that was very specific yeah very
specific somebody's been doing late
night Google research on how to entice a
bald eagle to eat an illegal alien and
that person's name is Joe DeVito Tom
you've heard the phrase straw man I'm
gonna steal man their defense I'm gonna
defend them they didn't steal anybody's
food right it's not like they went into
somebody's yard and stole the bird and
did they really know it was a bald eagle
they probably saw a big bird they were
probably hungry
um you know should they be fined you
know they could you can get fined like a
couple hundred grand for killing an
eagle well the thing how about this
don't do anything extra to them for uh
the bald eagle thing but they kind of
should be told to leave the country
anyway that's right how are they still
here yeah I mean it's if if you found
them at a Denny's you probably should
have said hey it's time to go back to
Honduras yeah uh but yeah I think
you know I mean so the eagle is just on
top of it but I think this is something
Trump obviously has to pick this up I
don't know why this is kind of a layup
frame yeah you remember the last time
when he said they're not sending their
finest people they're killing our Eagles
Birds yeah they're eating a Nebraska I
think it was Nebraska the Huskers that's
right also he talked about that's why he
was against the uh the wind farms
because the wind farms were killing the
birds yes you know so he's going to get
on this for sure the wind farms have
killed more bald eagles than uh the bird
flu a fact that I just made up
I have no idea cat cat where do you
stand on this story wouldn't it be great
if after they ate the bald eagle they
kneeled during the national anthem
yeah it's so on the nose like are we
sure that they've never had any phone
calls with Pete hugseth
to do this
as a friend's weekend
I was all over the place on this one
because at first I was like okay like I
feel bad for them because if you're
killing a bird to eat for dinner your
life kind of sucks and like it's
probably harder than my life and I
shouldn't you know but then I read more
and it's like okay they broke into
private property to do it and I feel
like breaking in a private property with
a gun that's a no-go yeah and then
killing and then the fact that they were
like we wanted to make the talons into
ornaments that was missing from like all
the stories that I read except except
for the New York Post of course and I
was like that just like changes things
mentally for me that like if you're in a
mental space where you're also like I'm
thinking about what part of this carcass
I can use for decorations
then that's just kind of weird you know
that's a good point however and I also
heard that these guys actually have
their own home
those bastards but I mean a lot of big
game Hunters a lot of people that we
admire they collect uh what would you
call souvenirs trophies trophies uh and
I'm gonna take an artificial stance here
in sunny maybe the bald eagle has had a
good run isn't it time for a new
national animal or bird I mean what
about the toucan no because then we have
to deal with Peter let's just leave it
where it is we don't have to go through
a prolonged fight with Peter
um I'm looking at it and I'm all I can
say you know the ball Eagle to side
understanding the symbolism all of that
I looked at and I was like masculinity
is back
[Laughter]
Man actually out hunting catching her
food you know what I'm saying and you're
like well he took they took the feet to
make uh ornament no these are men who
use every part of the bird they're not
letting any of it go to waste like this
is what America is made of give these
people citizenship
let's go and take some of the soy boys
and send them to Honduras and get a
couple of more Hunters up here in our
spaces
you guys applauded the murder of a bald
eagle that was all a trick by Sunny to
implicate all of you and our dirty sick
plan we also don't know what the bald
eagle did that's true that's true you
might be you know what in the bald eagle
Community what if he's yeah oh I'm glad
Steve's gone he would still be innocent
until proven guilty this is America
Steve was a real prick oh I'm a bald
eagle I'm a bald eagle he would do that
all the time
anyway it's because of the baldness they
have to compensate
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else